اه بشان الدعم الغربي كيف قال مسؤولون
امريكيون ان واشنطن تضع اللمسات الاخيره
على خطط لتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ باتريوت
للدفاع الجوي واضاف المسؤولون الامريكي قد
تعلن ارسال هذه الصواريخ الى اوكرانيا
خلال الاسبوع الجاري على ان يتم تدريب
الاوكرانيين على استخدامها في قاعده للجيش
الامريكي لالمانيا واوضح المسؤولون ان خطه
البنتاجون لارسال الصواريخ ما زلت بحاجه
الى موافقه وزير الدفاع وليد اوستن قبل
ارسالها الى الرئيس عليها
من جهاتها اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه في
تغريده ان رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اعلن
حزمه دعم للدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50
مليون جنيه
واضافت الخارجيه البريطانيه ان حزمه
المساعدات الجديده لاوكرانيا تتالف من 125
مدفعا مضدا للطائرات وتكنولوجيا لمواجهه
المسيارات الايرانيه
الجانب الروسي يتوعد بالرد على تزويد
اوكرانيا حيث قال ديميترميدف نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي انه اذا قام
الناتو حسبما لمح الامين العام للحلف ينسى
السلطان بتزويد من وصفهم بالمتعصبين في
كييف بمنظمات باتريوت مع عناصر من قوات
النيته فسيصبحون على الفوري هدفا مشروعا
للقوات الروسيه